Loïc Hervé vous êtes aussi président
délégué de l'Association des petites
villes de France comment vous réagissez
à la démission de ce maire sous la
pression sur la violence de l'extrême
droite ce qui se passe est extrêmement
grave évidemment les faits qui se sont
produits maintenant quelques mois de
l'incendie du domicile de sommaire mais
surtout sa démission ce cri d'alarme
d'ailleurs nous allons le recevoir au
Sénat dans quelques jours c'est
la manifestation d'un maire qui n'en
peut plus
qui a eu peur pour lui-même pour sa
famille j'ai moi-même vécu cette
situation de de
menaces de mort j'ai été protégé pendant
près d'un mois par la par la par la
gendarmerie c'est extrêmement dur à
vivre pour vous-même pour vous pour
votre famille donc
l'émotion est forte par rapport au fait
qui se produit par rapport à sa
démission
j'entendais que on pourrait
éventuellement renforcer encore le droit
pénal je pense que on touche on a fait
de sauter dans ce pays un tabou
qui est le fait que finalement sans
prendre à des élus c'est pas si choquant
que ça alors les émotions de l'émotion
est légitime notamment à gauche et je la
comprends et je la partage mais je pense
qu'il faut on devrait être beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus solidaire et beaucoup plus
aux côtés de ce maire qui démissionne et
pour marquer dans la société française
qui n'est pas possible de s'en prendre à
un maire et qu'on il doit pouvoir
continuer sa mission de merde
ce que pour vous il n'a pas été assez
protégé
par l'État vous savez quand je ne sais
pas je peux pas parler de je n'en sais
rien il nous le dira sans doute quand il
sera entendu par la commission des lois
et la mission comme moi j'ai été
concerné j'ai été protégé et à la fois à
l'époque Bernard Cazeneuve et le préfet
de département qui qui s'appelait George
François Leclerc tous les deux
m'ont protégé ont mis les mesures
nécessaires vis-à-vis de moi mais je
pense que ce soit pas le sujet le sujet
aussi ce sont ces groupuscules pour
Monsieur le Maire en question à
Saint-Brevin c'est des militants et des
groupuscules d'extrême droite qui
clairement s'en sont pris à lui pour moi
c'était plutôt la mouvance salafiste
pour d'autres ce seront des mouvements
d'extrême gauche donc dans ce pays pour
contrer la puissance de ces de ces
groupes musculaires on a l'impression
que les lois ne suffisent pas il y a
évidemment le droit pénal une fois qu'on
a confondu les auteurs
et puis il y a la prévention c'est à
dire que dans cette commune de
Saint-Brévin on a laissé régulièrement
se faire des manifestations contre le
maire donc l'axe de personnes qui n'ont
rien à voir avec la commune de
Saint-Brévin ah non mais c'est à dire
que c'est est-ce que c'est
manifestations qui ont qui avaient lieu
régulièrement dans cette commune et dont
le maire avait demandé qu'elle soit
interdite
elles ne l'ont pas été il faudra
d'ailleurs qu'on le regarde de manière
de manière objective quand la commission
des lois va entendre sa mère et qu'on
demande des comptes au préfet du
département aux différents ministres
concernés sur la le fait qu'on laisse
dans une commune qui il s'agit du
transfert d'un centre d'accueil de
demandeurs d'asile dans ma commune il y
en avait il y en avait un précisément et
c'est pour cristallisé qui a généré un
tel donc c'est compliqué la gestion pour
les îles locaux la gestion des cadas
c'est très compliqué
l'association des élus locaux à ces
structures là elle est très relative
donc il aussi des éléments
très concrets dans l'administration de
ces sujets là sur le terrier de les
territoires qu'il faut revoir rapidement
pour conclure sur ce sujet Loïc Hervé ce
qu'il faut des mesures supplémentaires
pour protéger nos élus alors on l'a voté
au Sénat à plusieurs reprises y compris
dans la dans la loi de programmation du
ministère de l'intérieur dont j'étais le
rapporteur avec Marc-Philippe de Bresse
dans cette dans cette maison ici au
Sénat évidemment il y a des mesures de
droit pénal à prendre mais je le redis
je pense qu'il y a des mesures de
prévention et que on peut pas quand une
situation se est délétère et et ce
cristallise sur une personne ou dans une
commune faut pas attendre que le
domicile du maire soit incendié et il
faut pas attendre que le maire
démissionne
de Saint-Brevin-les-Pins crée une
situation dans laquelle il y a un émoi
politique et qui est tout à fait
légitime et du soutien à son égard c'est
logique mais je pense qu'on allait trop
laisser traîner les choses on a laissé
dégénérer la situation on va parler du
fond
[Musique]